can you believe that we are sitting here
talking about season 24 of big brother
no i cannot believe it in fact when we
first launched our
premier season season one you know it
was a little dicey i remember people
saying like
are we gonna survive the whole season
so and here we are 24 seasons in and
it's actually even more because we've
had three celebrity seasons we don't
count and we had one that was um ott
just online so this was like the 28th
cycle
here we are
it's wild like i can't think of shows
that have had that long of a run other
than a soap opera really but big brother
is a sopra soap opera in its own way
absolutely it's a real life soap opera
you know with real people living
real life strangers
and just like a soap opera you have
drama you have tears you have laughter
you have romance we've had so many
marriages come out of this all that are
sticking people starting families um and
there's you know lots of silliness along
the way speaking of the romances and the
showmances when you first see the cast
do you ever sit down and go
um i think this person and this person
might have a connection or i think these
ones have you predicted any showmances
that have lasted
i
well i mean jeff and jordan that was
like the one that we were all rooting
for and the beauty of it is is that they
knew that they liked each other and they
didn't do anything
until they were out of the house
um but what i
like the most is when you hear of
couples
that start dating after the fact like
last year i thought derek
and um hannah would be a cute couple
only to find out after
the summer after big brother was over
derek and claire started dating they're
going strong and i love that you know so
you never know expect the unexpected
when it comes to show madnesses in the
big brother house
something else that you love that you
recently post about on instagram is you
posted a photo of yourself on the stage
and the caption read love being on the
stage
back soon what is the feeling you get
right before taking the stage for a
taping
well when we have a live audience it's
always like um
my adrenaline is like just running it's
i'm pumped i'm excited
um and it really hits an all-time high
when there have been a few times where
literally before the live show starts
the house is coming undone and it's
flipping like you think you're prepared
you think okay
someone says i was going to get evicted
tonight this is how the vote's going to
go down and then suddenly
things just get
blown apart
um but my heart usually races a little
bit
and um i get not nervous but like nerds
i get like excitement
uh
you know i love live i love live
television
well and speaking of live television and
speaking of the audience we've missed
the audience the past couple seasons
will we have an audience back in the
studio this season with you we were
hoping to at this point we are not going
to launch with a live studio audience
whether or not that changes by the end
of the summer here's praying i'm hopeful
that it will
i'm hopeful too i always feel like when
you have the audience there you kind of
also get a feeling as to
who people are liking who people are not
liking based off of reactions
yes you know i mean they will scream it
out like even before we go live they're
like i hope someone sell gauze tonight
or you know we love so and so um
and that always it's it's fun to watch
it's fun to see and also when the person
gets evicted for them to like walk out
you know instead of with their tail
between their legs then they walk out to
like a cheering crowd that you know we
love you and it's it's very uplifting
it's nice to feel it's nice to be a part
of and to see
with so much experience as the host of
big brother i'm curious do you think
you'd ever make a good house guest
i would make a terrible house guest
because i
it's not in my nature to deceive or to
lie you know i'm a journalist so i'm
always about the facts
i also have watched these competitions
like get so much harder over the years
you know i don't think i would be
fit physically to do some of these
things certainly not the endurance
challenges
no i
i i think i would be terrible i would
not be a good house guest at all
well it has me curious and what do you
think is the most important part to win
big brother is it having a strategic
game or is it having a physical game
i think it's having the ability to keep
your mouth shut
i think loose lips always sink someone's
game you know the person who did the
best was derek when he won you know no
one knew
who he was in alliance with no one knew
he was a private detective in real life
um so by nature he knew how to keep his
mouth shut it's when you run your mouth
too much whether you say too much and
you reveal things that are happening or
you think you're smarter than you are
and you try and like spread a rumor and
you wreak havoc that way and then you
hurt your own credibility in the house
so i think that is the hardest thing
derek's season was fabulous i remember i
think it was in a confessional he was
talking about how as an undercover
police officer he can read lips he can
see body language from a distance and in
that he also talked about trend
transforming himself he started to wear
the other house guest clothes to make
himself appear younger genius genius
um what can you tell us about this
season what is the theme what does the
house look like anything about the
guests how's that we have 16 brand new
house guests that you're going to meet
and hopefully you know fall in love with
we are doing a theme called bb fest
you know who doesn't like summer is full
of festivals we're going to have our own
you know renaissance fest music fest
comedy fest but my favorite is when we
have the zing fest i think that's going
to be the most fun
the theme of the house is very palm
springs mid-century
we're calling it the bb motel
and uh you know neon lights we've got a
tiki bar upstairs along what we call the
bridge outside the hoh bedroom
um and the challenges are new challenges
that we've never done before big brother
canada just finished its 10th season and
has been greenlit for an 11th season i'm
wondering as the host of big brother us
and erisa cost cox as the host of big
brother canada did the two of you have a
chat back and forth where you're talking
about big brother all the time
no we don't but we should start one
yeah absolutely
i think so all right well thank you so
much julie it was lovely to chat with
you i hope you have a great day thank
you for your time i appreciate you